will this be Todd and Julie Chrisley's
final Thanksgiving before heading to
prison welcome everyone to Entertainment
Tonight Kevin Frazier is going to join
us from New York in just a bit now while
the Chrisleys are preparing to spend
over a decade Behind Bars Jay Leno is as
free as a bird and ready to get back to
work
how you feeling Jay we all want to know
new video Jay pumping gas and feeling
the love
I appreciate that thank you now you're
going to be driving that car again
anytime soon which one the one that you
had the accident underneath oh yeah
probably didn't do anything wrong
72 year old suffered third degree burns
you can clearly see the injuries on his
ear lower lip and hand but like a true
comedian Jay's using the fiery accident
for jokes get some sleep yeah I need
barbecue
as part of his recovery Jay spent two
hours a day in a hyperbaric chamber an
hour in the morning an hour in the
afternoon we have skin grafts what can
you tell me about that process we put a
human cadaver skin to create an
environment in which his body can be
stimulated to heal you're going to be
performing very soon yeah I'll be
performing Sunday of Comedy magical his
upcoming show at the Hermosa Beach
Comedy Club quickly sold out it's good
to see you up and about Jay thanks guys
let's move from LA to Atlanta where Todd
and Julie Chrisley say they will appeal
their prison sentences for tax evasion
and 30 million dollars in bank fraud I
pray to God every day we made a
commitment that we were not going to
give up their attorney is claiming that
quote their trial was marred by serious
and repeated errors Todd was sentenced
to 12 years in prison his wife Julie 7.
so what's next
ET has learned no date has been set for
the Chrisleys to surrender also their
sentences will not be staggered so who
will care for 16 year old Grayson and
their 10 year old granddaughter Chloe 25
year old Savannah hinted on her podcast
that it could become her responsibility
I may come home Tuesday and I have
custody of the 16 year old and a 10 year
old and we spend our first Thanksgiving
not as a family it was important to send
a message that this type of behavior is
serious hot bench judge Rachel Juarez
tells E.T the Chrisley's on-camera
Antics hurt them in court there's no
dispute that during both the trial and
the sentencing the government used
significant evidence that they called
from the Chrisley's reality TV show